in the early days of DotA's competitive
history there were players who built
reputations so fearsome they were simply
referred to as gods this elite group of
players includes names such as Vegas
Lodha Marleny and yamete many of the old
gods have retired taking up jobs as
commentators and community builders or
are no longer the player they once were
however one such God continued to forge
his legacy at the top level of
competition playing among and against
the best long after many of his peers
stopped he is called the Emperor the be
God his anti-mage is the best in the
game's history he is sooo burning zeal a
and this is his story
kids in the village of tong ling in the
android province of china 2007 as the
son of a humble coal miner burnings
parents hoped for him to go to school
and have a good career but by this time
at the suggestion of his friends he had
played his first game of dota and the
dream of playing video games
professionally had taken root in
burnings mind the Chinese dota scene at
the time was blowing up giving rise to
the first generation of competitors
burning after forming a team called TT I
quickly gained attention for his
leadership and skills in the countless
online Cups over the next few years
burning was among the first to prove
China's relevance on the international
stage famously leading the underdog team
a7l to victory in the Tianyi Cup in 2009
over the russian powerhouse PS however
while his own star was constantly rising
between 2008 and 2009 burning often
bounced between teams due to the nature
of the Chinese scenes smaller pro
organizations which at the time were
woefully underdeveloped and in some
cases outright incompetent
needless to say by 2010 burning was not
only a highly sought-after talent but
had already earned his be God moniker as
one of the best players in China then in
January 2010 he accepted an offer to
join a home in a move that took his
career to the next level the roster
quickly became the best team in China
and ranked among the elite in the world
winning 10 tournaments that year
including IEM season 5 and the ESWC
World Cup burning already a household
name in China rocketed to the top
cementing his reputation as a lethal
superstar carry player his consistency
no matter the circumstances became
legendary and his performances
throughout 2010 are still talked about
to this day in January of 2011 burning
moved team DK with a ridiculous transfer
fee of 50,000 you'ens around 7,500 u.s.
dollars a record-setting price tag in
eSports at the time
however team DK was a mess for the first
six months posting poor results until
burning was able to recruit his old
teammates along didi as well as Zippo to
the team if the first half of the year
had been a disaster
following the roster refresh the back
half was nothing but unmitigated success
DK award to the top of the pack winning
nine tournaments to close out 2011 as
the dota 1 era began to wind down
burning was ranked as one of the best
carries in the world burn another kill
dominating sadly his success was cut
short following the introduction of dota
2 it started when team DK was invited to
compete at the first the international
but did not attend after officially
transferring versions in early 2012 the
new landscape would prove unkind to the
team they would post a mediocre results
and a few cups here and there but
nothing outstanding III new DK was
having a bit of a hard time recently
yeah but it's still DK thankfully DJ's
reputation was good enough to earn them
a spot at ti2
and decayed the second Chinese seemed to
now be removed from the international
they would end up finishing fourth at
ti2 a respectable placing but certainly
not living up to DK and burnings lofty
standards of no burnings performance on
his signature anti-mage at the event
especially against Dara was so
impressive that icefrog added burning as
an alternate in-game name for the hero
the end of 2012 and much of 2013 was a
time of frustration TDK
and most of China paled in the face of
the European powerhouses of not as
Finn's air and Alliance burning had yet
to win a title in DotA 2 and DK
who closed out dota 1 on top were not
even the best team in China anymore let
alone the world after having dedicated
five years of his life to competitive
dota burning now 24 years old began
publicly discussing retirement event we
you can adjust Yama just made only it
almost one half of our material
available so with one last shot at glory
in dota 2 burning entered into TI 3
hoping to close out his career in the
best way possible when the aegis of
champions one of the players is really
kind of stood out hair is being burning
he's being great but what do you what do
you guys make of their line
I think they're gonna be going in this
match with a real shot against taking
down the returning champions and he's in
the one remaining he stuck with him he's
form this new team and they've been
performing pretty well they finished
second in that group DK's started out
well into the group stage but finished
with another early exit this time in 5th
to 6th it seemed like back-to-back
disappointments at the international
combined with a parent burnout would
prompt the begun to say goodbye
Nadia were always young will te
thankfully burning opted not to retire
and went all in on winning a major dota
2 events burning assembled a team of
superstars from all across Asia
including ice ice ice mushi and Len M
with burning as their centerpiece DK set
out to win titles their first
international stop MLG Columbus did not
go according to plan
nobody picks it up they don't even need
the rapier they say we'll kill you
anyway
now same scene Snagit he's guy in
bad sword for himself
speed gaming Oh your champions here at
MLG Columbus but then DK finally broke
their drove they all just got up and
started cheering actually Lam blocks
over knocked over his monitor the rest
of the year was excellent for DK the
team was clicking well and their star
carries in mushi and burning ran
roughshod over even the stiffest of
competitions in fact burning one 150,000
dollars more in 2014 than he had in the
six previous years of his career
combined his career had been a success
before but 2014 was where it paid
financial dividends his parents could
stop worrying about his future and
support him in his quest to win a TI and
represent China with pride in fact he
would later buy them a large house
listen that is the jolly abundant that -
violet matter you don't fit on before
farms just a Johnny o Gama while their
form heading into ti4 wasn't as peak as
it had been at the start of 2014 many
predicted DK a strong contender to take
it all fans prayed burning would add the
aegis of Champions to his already loaded
trophy case unfortunately it was not to
be this is one of the weirdest game of
games I've seen in a long while because
neither team seems interest or actually
vici are interested in fighting but DK
know they can't fight they don't stand a
chance in these fights yes 18 minutes in
VG gaming in the first game of the day
have brought the paddle and spanked DK
the loss was devastating to burning he
had delayed retirement put this all into
assembling a superstar roster and still
a title at the international eluded him
burning already plagued with a doubt
officially announced his retirement on
August 17 2014 while he would stay with
DK as a coach for their new squad his
time playing was done
and the end of the career of their God
looking back on his accomplishments with
pride but the lingering question of what
could have been it was the end of the
road for burning or was it big God I
shown that you cannot forget how to play
dota overnight the team of Chinese
retirees have had a dominating
performance in the group stage ending
second despite not being a serious team
just a few months later in December
burning joined big gods a retirement
team if you will
consisting of himself his friend rotk
Lanham Mikasa and Shou wait
initially the team was slated to only
appear in a league season too but they
would also play in the dota 2 Asia
Championships in early 2015 it was clear
that burning wasn't ready to fully leave
the game hind and dota wasn't done with
burning either in fact the teams a
fourth place finish which saw them go
toe-to-toe with some of the best teams
in the world proved the old men of
Chinese dota still habits a futile
effort by boat 7 phyto next on the lists
Big Daddy to fall as well in BG run
right over cloud nine who look lost so
far his strong form prompted burning to
rejoin the ranks of high-level
competition and in March of 2015 he
signed with Invictus gaming while
burnings official return to the pro
scene wasn't quite as dominant as many
fans would have liked i G posted modest
results so throughout the year their
best being second at the starladder star
series season 12 TI 5 however was a flop
burnings worse placing at the tournament
yet
man down this one hurt splints and it
feels so good for secret people still
respected burning and his legacy was
undeniable but having come out of
retirement the results were not where
they needed to be a switch to vici
gaming in September didn't help in the
slightest a way to come back during this
incredibly difficult time burning skills
like many players his age were beginning
to wane however his experience as a
player was still invaluable and he was a
decorated leader so somewhere in the
first week of March he switched to
support that didn't help either forcing
them to pull vici gaming GG is what we
expected from the railroad through
stages a home showing us why they are
without a doubt one of the strongest
teams of China yeah things not really
coming into place for vici gaming that
the Soliman thinks and those people had
a lot of faith in just wasn't enough to
carry this fruit and 2016 would prove to
be the worst year of burnings career by
a mile
VG it didn't even qualify for ti6
thereunto the tip for both their onto
the base been there onto the grand
finals vici gaming taken down by their
visit the child Simon the reborn Avicii
Oh juice chocolate if it's too strong
burning stuck with it and towards the
end of the year there was a glimmer of
hope
burning returned to IG as their one
position carry but this time he was
surrounded by rookie talent for the
first time in ages burning was on a team
of inexperienced players whose potential
was tremendous um this is a guy who if
he'd gone the path of other Chinese
stars could years ago have stopped
playing professionally and just say
focused on streaming he'd be well off
the rest of his days but there's that
one mountain left to climb it's Ti and
so he's still here the progress was slow
it was clear this version of IG had what
it took
burning slowly returned to form
complemented by the tactical brilliance
of cue the talent of Opie and xxs and
their star support stylings of lo Boca
the team a steadily improved and in
March of 2017 burnings patience and
dedication paid off
[Applause]
[Applause]
many agreed burning was the MVP of DAC
2017 and he had one of the biggest
titles of the year to prove it
the Emperor if temporarily had returned
to his throne his play at the tournament
was spectacular like watching a God long
dormant come again sadly it was the last
taste of true success burning has had a
fleeting reflection of his former glory
I I would like to to put burning as the
MVP simply because I really like the
story line up like this truly is the
return of burning it's the return of a
God okay China as well yeah since then
IG has slowly declined posting 56th at
the past four premier events including
ti7 I think they're a team that they
want DAC as a major tournament and since
then they've been slumping slumping
slumping the time of the emperor had
once again come to an end and as of
September 6th he has been inactive on
Invictus gaming the future is uncertain
for burning now 29 years old and having
already flirted with permanent
retirement in the past a return to dota
must surely be a difficult decision for
the B God through sponsorship collapses
roster breakdowns poor results and even
retirement his legacy has only grown
with time they know that there's going
to be no TV back up so immediately Katie
closes in and he's got the double guy oh
he's go to the mind games there he's
doing it
no burning there with the illusion mike
cronin the standstill hold your breath
and hope for the best play at the chat
wheel he is a player whose name is
literally inscribed in the very game to
which he dedicated the better part of
the past decade his glory days of the
past are what made him a god but his
dedication to climb back to the top are
what make him a hero should he decide to
return or call it quits for good
dota will always remember burning thanks
for watching if you want more great
content be sure to hit that subscribe
button
[Music]